edc is getting underway at the las vegas
motor speedway the first performance
about to start in about an hour victoria
saha is joining us live from the
speedway and victoria festival goers can
now stay and play there
there's so many people camping out here
there are tons to rent even a spot for
rvs thousands of people are expected to
be here at the speedway speedway for the
three-day event
lines of cars pulling into the
campgrounds a glimpse of just how busy
this weekend will be at edc over the
next three days 400 artists will be
taking the stage fans i spoke with are
ready to rave we've been here since last
night it's kind of hectic with pulling
everything in but all in all it's pretty
worth it yeah yeah for sure i love the
vibes love the energy everybody brings
it out with the fellow campers so sick
it was supposed to be a big group for us
and then once the event keeps on
cancelling back in 2020 and 2021 a lot
of our
friends were not able to go on those
dates
but for this time i was only one stan
one man standing and these festival
goers are prepared to spend a lot of
money some even saying the campground
cost them one thousand dollars for three
days
when i checked earlier today i did not
see any tickets available i also checked
the shuttles provided by edc those are
sold out as well you are encouraged to
take a taxi or a ride share the festival
grounds here open at five o'clock
reporting by the speedway victoria saha
live local now thank you